Silicon Valley has lost a giant Andy
Grove the former Intel CEO author and
mentor who helped pioneer the modern
computing industry passed away at the
age of 79 Grove was the epitome of
self-made success he survived the
Holocaust and the Hungarian Revolution
he came to the US with nothing yet he
put himself the University receiving a
PhD in chemical engineering in the 60s
Grove climbing the ladder at the seminal
Silicon Valley company Fairchild
Semiconductor when the founders of Intel
poached Grove he didn't stop climbing
moving up from director of engineering
to president to CEO under his guidance
Intel was transformed from a struggling
memory chipmaker into the processor
Titan it is today outside the valley
Grove might not have the name
recognition of some of his proteges but
among Tech's most influential leaders
he's routinely mentioned as part of the
same Pantheon that includes Bill Gates
Larry Ellison and Steve Jobs for all his
success Grove never stopped learning and
giving he left Intel in 1998 following a
prostate cancer diagnosis after his
recovery he dedicated himself to
philanthropic causes Grove overcame
enormous odds to run a company that
still makes the technology that powers
our laptops desktops and computer
servers the machines that power today's
economy